just take  bishop d5 tattooing knight d4  dominating the knight on a5 poor knight  and really um  bishops if i've played of course  yeah there's no is that rizal oh what do  you think  what do you think he's saying he's he's  aiming he resigned  and duda wins the world cup  congratulations to  yan shisht of duda what a tournament  eliminate the world champion in the  semi-finals  now in the finals the vice world  champion of the year 2016.  sega kayaking amazing event for  the 23 year old poll  winning this event first place and  qualifying for the candidates  congratulations amazing amazing  performance  um i will just congratulations to him  that was brilliant you you just beat the  world champion magnus carson in the  semi-finals  beating sergey kayak in the final uh  just amazing mr world cup basically uh  sargokin what so many brilliant results  in  in world cup so sisters more than  100 deserved brilliant we